very happy to tell you that Josh Groban
is in the house in the studio we welcome
you Josh it's so good to see you again
such a pleasure to see you I feel the
same about you so here's what USA Today
said about you uh his Lush baritone is
unsurprisingly a glorious match for
Sondheim ballots and when he does
unleash Sweeney's monstrous side and
Epiphany in the actu climates this is
the line that got me Josh romit is
downright terrifying to behold I just
don't think of terrifying and Josh
Groban in the same sentence but you are
nailing this role thank you very much
it's been a lot of fun it's a it's you
know it's a role that uh that has so
many different nuances to it and it and
he wrote it for Lush singing and and
there is a lot of Romanticism to the to
the music in it but juxtaposed with all
of the you know heinous acts that are
happening that's what makes the show so
interesting to me I mean Josh you were
literally slitting people's throats I
know it's acting but you do it with such
Flair and you do it with such ease what
does it say about you Mr Groban well I
mean what does it say about you listen
Sweeney Todd was Benjamin Barker before
he before he got off the boat and before
he um you know these terrible things
happened to him there was a human being
there who was married who you know made
his baby girl laugh and had a family
life and at some point this this very
human person wanted to come back wanted
to find his wife and wanted to seek
Justice and then slowly but surely under
pressure and under the circumstances he
snaps and that's that's I think the
thing that really drew me to the role
right now was how do you find the person
who never knew that he was going to be
the bad guy yes uh in this but how are
we laughing at this Josh because I found
myself the audience we're laughing out
loud as we're watching you know this
murder in Mayhem being committed well
what is it you and Annalee together by
the way are magic I love working with
Anna Lee we've got we've got such a
wonderful chemistry it's just it's great
to have a partner out there who balances
uh the light in the dark with you and
um and and there is a lot of humor
there's very dark humor that Sondheim
really wanted in this he wanted people
to let it let out that Steam and to
laugh and you know and so it's a it's we
want it to be a thrilling good time for
people and so when you hear them gasping
and you hear them crying but then you
hear them letting out the laughter you
know you've done the right thing but you
say this is a role that you've coveted
listen back when you were a teenager
yeah and we have proof of this you go to
camp and you audition for Sweeney Todd
that's right yes you wanted this role
well I I the wonderful interlocking Arts
camp in Michigan was doing Sweeney Todd
I had just at that point and we have you
there ah there I am there you are I
played a painter I think they had me in
an outfit to be a painter uh wonderful
being in The Ensemble of that production
it's some of the most incredible
Ensemble music ever written
um and I auditioned to be Sweeney I was
you know even our Sweeney that year
um Rob rokiki who's a composer now
um you know we were all young but I was
really young so it was too young then uh
42 now is the right age well what I
think is so great uh Katie Smith who
produces segment when she was talking
she heard about that she she called the
camp and they said of course we still
have pictures so to be able to have
pictures of you to see guys yeah to see
that you this was something that you
wanted to do and now here you are on
Broadway doing this well when you're
young to you it's it's so full circle I
try not to let how emotional and full
circle and how what a powerful
experience this is for me affect me too
much on things like opening night where
we had the original Sweeney Len carry
who was sitting out there we were so
honored your parents and their parents
are there your significant others there
absolutely Natalie we just and we just
we we just I just you have to like leave
that off stage you have to leave that
stage left and go out and immerse
yourself in it because if you let too
much of that you know permeate
um it can be sometimes nerve-wracking so
um I've Loved this show I've Loved
sondheim's work everybody in the cast I
know feels very full cast is so good I
mean I have to just say to the viewers
who are watching I'm I swear to you I'm
not late to the Josh Groban party there
was a show back in the day called Ally
McBeal that's right and you sang uh to
where you are you're still you you're
and I went to the producers I was
working at oxygen at the time that said
if we can ever get this Josh Groban guy
to come in I will come in on my day off
to talk to him a month later they said
Gail we got Josh Groban were you serious
about coming in on your day off and I
was I came in now 25 years later I'm
coming in on my day off to come see you
so
much back around that's theater I mean
when I had a show back in the day look
at a shot look at us I was about uh I
was 2010 I think yeah you still look the
same I know what you're saying so I
remember saying to Oprah you look the
same I I know you I've earned but good
you're a grown ass man and you look good
I remember saying to Oprah when I first
heard you I said he makes the hairs on
the back of my neck stand up you should
listen to this guy and she goes he
sounds uh he sounds gonna go no no no
listen again he sounds so good so for my
birthday she wanted to surprise me and
you were sick that day but then Oprah
cooked up another surprise it's it's
something I'll never forget yeah and
Josh surprises me at work yeah rotate
please oh my goodness
okay we're on our way to the office now
getting all jittery well then you know
what you ought to have a really good
time at the concert oh my God
hold on a second nobody has any idea how
are you guys
this better not be your people
[Music]
[Applause]
no so the backstory yeah success Oprah
called me up because I was going to see
you that night I've seen Josh in concert
four times I was and she was saying
you're gonna have a really great time in
this camera crew walks and I'm like who
are you people and then you walk in Josh
I'll never forget that I'll never forget
and you were singing the song to Oprah
on the phone yes when you say you love
me that I wind up singing to you that
day surprises are hard but yeah but you
pulled that off we nailed it you pulled
that off so do you know your next move
or do you even think like that because I
think about how you got started David
Foster says I know this great singer you
said in for Andrea Bocelli and the rest
is history and there you are you know I
think that diving head first into
something as challenging and rewarding
as as this
um it it you know it empties your tank
in some ways you got to keep finding
ways to refill every night but then it
also really fills your creative tank to
think about other things and so while I
might have a loose idea of what I want
to do next the kind of album I want to
make or whatever else
um I kind of let the chills guide me
this this was something chills this was
a big risk and you know something
something about this said to me you know
whatever happens this is something I'm
going to be really really passionate
about and whenever I've done something
for that reason it's always worked out
well you nailed it please know I'm here
cheering you on always well thank you so
much whenever you decide you want to get
married I'll you know my address I'll
sit on the groom side of the family just
throw it out there Josh Groban I'm happy
in all parts of your life and your mom
and your dad tell myself hey I feel the
same thank you thank you my friend you
can see Josh and Sweeney Todd on
Broadway at the Fontan theater right now
right now run don't walk